[Music]
good evening I'm Jesse Watters in for
Laura Ingraham and this is the Ingraham
angle from new york thank you for
watching the special the Trump agenda in
2018 and that agenda just got a huge
head start when President Trump signed
the sweeping 1.5 trillion dollar tax cut
into law this morning we had the largest
tax cuts in our history just approved
and I was going to wait for a formal
signing sometime in early January but
then I watched the news this morning and
they were all saying will he keep his
promise will he sign it by Christmas
it's an honor to have you with us and we
will sign this right now this is
something I'm very proud of great for
our country great for the American
people thank you all looking forward to
2018 this tax cut could be a huge
difference maker right now Democrats
think they're poised for big gains in
the midterm elections because of polls
showing the supposed unpopularity of
both the president and the tax cut but
if those cuts to make an already humming
economy really take off the president
and the GOP will be in the driver's seat
come November Trump seems ready to roll
he already revealed one of his top
priorities for early 2018 before heading
the Mahr lago for the Christmas break I
really do believe we're going to have a
lot of bipartisan work done and maybe we
start with infrastructure because I
really believe infrastructure can be
bipartisan
we've spent 7 trillion dollars in the
Middle East
not to mention all of the lives and all
of the heartache and it's so sad 7
trillion dollars it's time for us to
rebuild our country the president may
finally get that bipartisan support
it would seem difficult for Democrats of
all people to argue against more
domestic spending so much to talk about
let's bring in our guests Fox News
contributor and former adviser of the
president dr. Sebastian Gorkhas in
Washington and civil rights attorney and
talk radio host Leo Terrell is in Los
Angeles California so doctor I'll start
with you Trump will have to run along
with his allies in Congress on reality
they can point to people's
and say there that's the tax cut
Democrats on the other hand are running
on emotion they're running on Envy and
they're saying the rich are bad and
you're getting hosed do you think that's
gonna be hard for the Republicans to out
message look Jesse first things first
thanks for having me and congratulations
on that sterling speech you gave at
twenty point USA the day before
yesterday
thank you very much that was quite quite
quite a speech flattery will get you
everywhere doctor I try but what are the
Democrats going to run on we have three
and a three percent GDP growth rates
already a million and a half jobs
created the lowest unemployment in
seventeen years everybody who pays tax
is going to get a tax cut what are they
going to run on I just don't see the
message let's remind ourselves
Jesse President Obama was the only
president since the depression who never
reached 3% GDP growth rate for one year
for his whole eight years in office the
2018 is going to be incredible for the
president it's going to be incredible
for all Americans whether you voted for
him or not you will have an incredible
2018 so Leo the point is is the
Democrats have not taken any ownership
of the economy they didn't vote for the
tax cuts
they've been against everything the
president's been doing so when the
economy's humming along they can't claim
any credit is that gonna be difficult
for the Democrats to run against a
soaring economy you know this I want to
win this argument by using Republican
principles today with President Trump
sign that bill he threw Republicans in
blue states under the bus there's a
reason why Republicans voted against
this bill let me tell the American
public Americans in New York California
are going to be double tax now they're
going to have the disadvantage of pain
not only a federal tax but stated local
tax they have wiped out the interest
deduction on mortgage and let me tell
you how important that is it is amazing
how Republicans like Peter King like
Dana Rohrabacher
and like their eyes have said this bill
is not good and you know what selling
this bill is going to be very tough
because even
Oh Fox News contributor Karl Rove said
mr. president stay in the White House
because you're unpopular right now
president President Trump could not sell
free groceries to the American public
not so sure but you make a good point
though about the New York and California
people I'm probably going to get
hammered and that's fine I understand
that but for the majority of Americans I
mean you see AT&T announcing Comcast's
announcing they're showering workers
hundreds of thousands of workers with
thousand dollar Christmas bonus checks
as a result of the tax cut dr. Lorca I
know your your guest likes autocratic
presidents like President Obama who
thinks they can dictate everything that
happens in this country but we have
states rights and the president can't
help it if California or New York or
Connecticut is hosing the people that
live there that's the state's decision
to do so and if you don't like it in New
York and Connecticut you can do
something about it as a voter I was in
Nevada this week I was stumping for
Danny Tarkanian
they hosted the event in the extreme
manufacturing headquarters they make
those extendable forklift trucks think
of this one thing biggest manufacturer
of these forklift trucks last year each
of these cost two hundred thousand
dollars last year they sold 115 Jesse
thanks to Donald Trump thanks to the
unleashing of the economy extreme
manufacturing has a back order of 900
units that's the Trump effect
let me just doctor Gorka answer these
two questions fundamental American
principle to be a homeowner to buy a
home every American homeowner got holes
because right now the interest deduction
on mortgage rates have been eliminated
more importantly what happened to the
old traditional fiscal conservative
spending cuts went with tax cuts where's
Paul Ryan's videos all of a sudden we're
gonna forget about spending cuts this
tax bill adds 1.5 million dollars to the
deficit where's all the fiscal
conservative Republicans working you
want to take this 100 you will Rachel
I'll take half of it
and I already know what's going to be on
the agenda in 2018 they want to try to
get some sort of welfare reform done
which will cut spending and a lot of
people are predicting massive growth as
a result of the tax cut which is going
to bring in more revenue to the federal
government dr. Gorka do you want to
finish off that point I just have to so
suddenly the left cares about spending
President Obama doubled doubled the
money this nation owns in comparison to
every other president that came before
him suddenly they care about how much
money the federal government is wasting
come on guys lets be cereal using so
many republican talking points i think
you might have to change your part no oh
no I'm just I'm just showing they
hypocrisy yeah about what the
Republicans are saying this is so unlike
Republican more importantly Trump you
just find the execution worn for every
blue state congressional Republican
because you know what like Karl Rove Fox
News contributor said president stay in
the White House Melissa tea so now he
has no credibility hold on dr. Gorka
let's let's lay off our own contributors
here for a second the house is under
siege I agree that historically it flips
when the other party's out of power I
get that but you know what the DNC's
broke they only have up about four
million dollars cash on hand the RNC has
about forty five million dollars of cash
on hand they're gonna need to fundraise
a little bit more if they think they're
gonna win back anything let me hit that
out of the park right now in Alabama in
December guess what yeah we're Democrats
came out in December of two eighteen
then the 2014 midterm elections those
are numbers telling you the Democrats
are going to create a storm in 2018 and
they're gonna take over the midterm
election there are people who are upset
with this president can't sell groceries
can't sell free groceries because you
know what he's alienated the American
public with his rhetoric doctor go ahead
the only people upset with this
president are the people who don't
understand why America
chose him on November the 8th and who
know that if this economy keeps on
trucking that they're in trouble the
Democrat Party is now predicated on one
thing Jesse and it's really sad it is
predicated on this president failing on
and on this economy failing that's on
American to wish that people don't get
tax breaks to wish that you shouldn't
get a bonus from AT&T why would you do
that
everybody's boat can be can rise
everybody's boat can float but no I'm
going to have to you you you keep
talking about those bonuses those bonus
we were a promise job not bonuses
bonuses are one-time giveaway job you
you bring me back in 12 months and let's
see what the impact of this tax cut
listen there's already three million
jobs created since the president came
into office so wages are gonna be years
old of this and jobs come on the thing
hasn't even kicked in yet are you
willing to give it a chance more than a
million people more than a million
people in less than a year have been
taken off food stamps suckling on their
government teat and come back to work
how can you not be thankful that that
can happening okay okay say it's easy
you're changing suck I want stick oh
that's great you're gonna make you can
make it as something you're making a
massive assumption that these these
corporations are not going to buy back
your stock is to their incentive to buy
back their stock because these
executives will get nice huge bonuses I
know this I've studied this I'm Lea okay
guarantee they'll get mom-jo you're the
only one yeah it could complain how
about American workers getting thousand
dollar bonus checks you're getting jobs
I don't want I don't want tip money I
want a job it's okay it's not I want a
job Lia Thomas John must be living large
I've never tipped the G with a job
listen bonus with a job listen I I think
let's wait I'll see how it plays out the
Leo man too
and a thousand different well I need to
come work for you bring me back in
twelve months and let's see how many
jobs were created all right I gotta go
guys thank you very much
Merry Christmas